- You know, I've...
I've stole from my own
grandmother, you know.
I've stole from people I love the most.
I'm not there for my daughter.
I don't even know my kid.
And it's funny because
out of all this fancy
stupid shit I get everyday,
you only get about 5% of what
you take as a thief, you know?
And the job we're doing...
Like I had a stepdad growing up.
He was like well off and
his family was well off
but they worked their
asses off to get there.
And he always said, this
one thing, you know,
it was a job worth doing
is worth doing well.
So if I'm going to be a shitty person,
might as well be good at it, you know?
And so I've taken that kind of philosophy
to the point of going into
some of the most secure
financial businesses and
districts across the country,
and exploited their security flaws.
And then had 15 laptops
and not a single person
would touch them because
they just came out of some,
wherever the hell.
And you're like, "Damn ,I
just put in eight hours,
carried about a hundred
pounds worth of gear
and I can't sell a single fucking laptop?"
You know what I mean?
"It's unlocked, I
unlocked it my damn self."
And it makes me feel like
"Damn, I put in a lot
of fucking work dude for,
for nothing." So then you get to the
frustrating part of your life
where you're just like,
"You know what, fuck it
If it's not...
If nobody wants it, then I'm
just going to destroy it."
At least I know where my work
starts and ends, you know?
I'm not going to leave
all these loose ends,
but doing that and to think
of like, when I was working
and how much money I put into taxes
and then to see what people do with
the tax money I worked so hard for
it's such a...
It's so confusing.
You know?
I don't know what to...
Where to start, you know, like.
- [Mark] How old are you?
- I'm 27.
- [Mark] 27.
And are you using drugs?
- Yeah. Yeah, sadly.
- [Mark] Which ones?
- I told my buddy pretty much any drug.
I guess the real drug I don't really
find a need for is cocaine.
Believe it or not.
I've never seen the glory and spending
a crazy amount of money on nothing.
I don't get it. (laughs)
- [Mark] How long have you been using
like heroin and meth?
- I've been
using...
Oh, it started out as, you know,
smoking weed at like 13, you
know, at 12, 13 years old.
I didn't smoke cigarettes
at all until I was 18.
So started out with weed at like 12, 13
and then went to ecstasy at like 15.
And then it was like, once
I tried a couple of them
I was just like, "Yes, this is awesome.
I'm going to just do
this shit all the time."
So then it progressed on like eating MTMA
or MDA until I was
about 17, 17 and a half.
And then that's when the really
cheap meth craze really hit
up where I'm from in Seattle.
And so it hit around 17, 18.
And then I went into that.
I got the opportunity
cause I started slipping
up and I knew better.
I got this phone call from my uncle
and he said, well, he said,
"Hey, you want a better job?"
Cause I was working at
a discount tire company
and he's like, "Yeah I got a
job for you waiting right now.
$27,50 an hour to start."
I'm like, "No shit.
I can do the right thing, make
money and go kick some ass."
You know?
So I went off North Dakota
and I made $7,200 my first paycheck,
and I stayed clean off of amphetamines,
and I took pain pills on occasion
but I never really chased it, you know?
And at that point,
so I spent all my money
on partying with alcohol
and stuff like that.
And then about month
and a half into working
in the oil field out in North Dakota,
my uncle who was my crew chief, saw that
I was starting to get exhausted you know?
I was about 170 pounds in
good, mildly decent shape.
I never made it.
I didn't graduate high school.
I dropped out of high
school when I was 15,
but I was in like the
standard, non going to
any physical education.
A typical teenager build, you know?
That's tall and gangly and stuff.
And I remember it like it was yesterday.
He passed me back to this
little pipe or whatever
and I hit it like twice
and I was so stunned,
cause it was right before
this meth nowadays.
It was real crank or
whatever they call it from
out in the middle of BFE, you know?
And I was hooked,
like straight hooked.
And...
- [Mark] At what age was that?
- I was 18.
- [Mark] 18.
- I spent, it was $200.
I spent $33,000.
33,000 in about a month,
like a month and a week ish
on crank.
Yeah, real crank and
shit, partied my as off.
I had a great time for like
the next year straight.
And then I ran out of money.
I lost my job because
I could not be stable
and made actually damn near
schizophrenic, you know?
Made me go crazy
and chasing women and stuff.
Next thing you know,
I'm broke living at my
grandma's in Washington again.
Have a girlfriend with
me that crazy beautiful,
but she's starting to, you
know, I'm not putting it
in her face at all, she's there, so,
you know, she's doing it.
And
wondering what fuck am I doing.
You know?
So-
- [Mark] Did your family know of your-
- Yeah, my mom.
- [Mark] The situation.
She's an addict as well.
My whole family on one side of my family,
they're all going through
addiction really bad.
- [Mark] Oh, yeah?
- Yeah. My cousin just died.
My cousin Graham, rest in peace.
He's like my...
He's a good dude.
That guy can steal any car
with any key I've ever seen.
I've never seen it before.
I've tried thousands of times.
He can hop in a Jeep with a Toyota key
and start right up.
I'm like, "God, that's
just a damn miracle."
Do it like it.
Could come in handy if it's 30 below zero
and you're about to die,
but like in, in a practical
sense, it's horrible.
You know what I mean?
But he was born into it kind of as well.
And like my mom was clean
and sober for 10 years.
First like memories I have in my life
is going to treatment
with her for like a year.
You know, I grew up in
a treatment facility
and my mom she used to
be a stripper and like,
she's really pretty, you know?
And she always had the dude you, knew.
She always had the dude, you know, and
thought that attention
was better than what
I guess society deems is the correct thing
and whatnot ,but...
So I lost a lot of...
I didn't really get to know my mom on like
a mom level, you know?
I got to know her as like a friend
and I always had these
dudes in and out of my life.
And then she finally meets
this dude in treatment,
of course,
and falls in love with him.
And he's on this righteous
path to getting right,
and she wants that, but
she doesn't, you know?
So it's like...
Do you mind if I put it on?
- [Mark] No, it's fine,
- Okay.
Anyways, I...
I watched my mom go
from living at these...
On these couches and random places
to
me sitting here
and watching my family become a family.
When we went from the
one bedroom apartment
to the three bedroom,
or the two bedroom.
and then from the two
bedrooms to the house,
the first house.
And then I watched my parents
finally get their dream house
and build it, but they
weren't happy, you know?
Something's was always off
and when they would have a problem,
it felt like they always
place blame on me, you know?
And so I left the house
early as a kid, I was gone.
I was like, all right,
you guys have issues.
I'm tired of feeling bad for
myself for no reason, you know?
So I'm going to fill that void with drugs.
And because the fact is is that
I don't have all the money in the world
and you guys are very like
weird about your money.
I'm gonna have to get a laptop for school
cause I got into a good school, you know?
So I started out with stealing to...
For my education, it was
originally why I stole.
But then I got caught by my parents
with having a stolen laptop from school
and they made me turn it
in and do the right thing.
And I ended up getting
completely kicked out
of that school for it.
And then after that I was
just like, "Fuck school.
I'm gonna go work."
So I got my GED when I was 15
and went to work,
and got my...
I rented a room from these
people who were in the military.
At 15, I had two jobs.
Was about to get into the military
which I thought I could with the GED.
And then I threw it all away.
I gotten a DUI.
I hit a fire hydrant
and became a meth addict.
(laughs)
- [Mark] And how long have
you been out here on Skid Row?
- Skid Row?
I pulled into town.
I stole four cars.
I had a dream of going to LA, right?
And
I fell in love.
She broke, you know...
I broke my own heart really.
And
I needed a way down
here and being paranoid
and always thinking every
big brother's after me
or whatever the hell, I ended up
procuring four cars,
four different vehicles.
Got to San Francisco
and realized I'm not gonna
try and do that anymore
cause it's not being very successful, so.
So I ended up catching a
Greyhound down here about two,
two and a half weeks ago.
I got off the Greyhound and
ran into my first, I guess,
event, which was walking down the street,
trying to find some drugs to smoke
cause I had $10 in my
pocket, last 10 bucks.
And this dude bought,
you know, doing his thing
on the street corner.
He was like, "Hey".
I was like, "Yeah, dude. I'm
trying to find, you know,
I need some speed or whatever."
He said "Yeah. Yeah."
And
ended up making a good friend and
being on the streets and figuring it out
out here without any
resources, no cell phone,
nothing, literally with
just the clothes on my back.
- [Mark] What are you doing for money now?
- I dress in a suit
and tie, some little...
Mainly and
I try to clean up as
humanly possible as much.
And I go into those really big skyscrapers
and I walk in and I go
and wait for somebody to
just not pay attention
and I slide to the back
and take an emergency
stairwell up to the 20th floor,
a butter knife, popup, you know,
just a butter knife, opens
the door for security.
Bam, you have full access
to multi-millions of dollars
worth of resources.
- [Mark] All right.
- It's incredible.
And so I'll go and just a notary stamp
in a picture of a signature,
just to know what it looks like
and what their code is,
and then notary stamp gets
you unlimited amount of money.
I walk out with...
I walked out with 15
laptops the other day.
- [Mark] Oh, you're basically stealing.
- Yeah, but walking right
out in front of them,
not even trying to hide it.
In a suit and tie.
- [Mark] Right.
Yeah. It's incredible.
- [Mark] [Indistinct] downtown
and hit those buildings-
- And then come down to Skid Row
and get rid of them for
pennies on the dollar.
- [Mark] Right.
- Anonymously.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- Yeah, it's a lot of work.
I mean I got cellulitis in my leg.
I probably need to get my leg amputated
if I don't like keep taking care of it.
- [Mark] But...
So, I mean, do you have hopes
of getting back together
with your kids or your-
- That's...
Honestly, that's what I'm doing this for.
It sounds crazy, but I hit...
I came upon quarter million
dollars in gold last year
and I fucked it all off.
I didn't realize what I
had cause I was impatient
and I was also,
you know, playing the game, they call it.
And
- [Mark] What do you mean you...
How'd you come across $250,000 of-
- I broke into a house.
- [Mark] You broke into a house?
- And I don't really ever do that.
Does that explained to
women's watch you're wearing
on your hand? (laughs)
- No, this came out of a car.
- [Mark] Oh, is it?
- Sadly.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- I don't, again, it's
not like I break windows.
I don't like to do any
of that kind of shit
but like a Rolex only got me 400 bucks
and in San Francisco of
all places, you know?
You know,
I like to play Robin Hood.
Like I go and I take advantage
of this white privilege
shit because it is real.
And I see people out here
who genuinely
truly try their hardest
to survive
and not just to survive,
but to keep a level head and to like...
It's inspiring to see how
some of these people can live
and keep a positive mindset
because I've always been
a really positive person
and going through like my
trials and tribulations,
I like being happy.
And I like when the world is happy too.
And like we're all in a harmony, you know?
And it sucks to have to be that guy.
But you know, I do
pretty good about keeping
my guilt from like,
getting to me, you know?
It's like once every three weeks or so,
I'll break down,
because my guilt, my
conscience will just...
it's not like I sleep at night
and have nightmares or nothing,
but I've died six times
in my life, you know?
Been brought back.
- [Mark] From what?
- Accidental overdose
cause I don't use needles.
Just smoking this fentanyl
shit here in town.
It's the most deadly thing
I've ever seen in my life.
I've been smoking drugs forever.
I hit it one time a week ago, I hit it.
- [Mark] Super dangerous.
One hit killed me.
And then purposeful overdose,
I've done that twice.
I hated myself.
I fell in love and I
wasn't able to be a man
that I feel like I deserve to be.
So I tried killing myself
and it didn't work.
So stopped trying that.
I died from exhaustion.
I was climbing buildings and
rappelling through the
skylights and stealing safes.
And all by myself in the
middle of the pouring rain,
I broke two ribs in my back
and suffocating myself.
Yeah. Rappelling off a building, slipped.
I also...
just a few other ways, you know, like.
But my heart gave out
this one time and I had a felony warrant
and I was so spooked that
I was gonna go to jail.
And I was going through
a really rough time
in my heroin addiction
and I was dope sick.
And I was looking for anything,
anything to help me get that next fix.
And I'm riding my bike down
this international Boulevard
or Pacific highway that goes all the way
from Mexico to Canada, pretty much.
And I was driving on Pacific highway
and I felt like this weird
flutter and my right leg
had been acting up, like
swelling up and stuff.
So my right leg had swollen up
probably got two thirds at the time,
the size it is now. Like
one and two third size.
And my left arm went
numb, started tingling.
And all of a sudden I like collapsed.
And I had like no energy, couldn't move.
And that was the first
time I really did die.
Like, and it scared the out of me.
And I had a dream about it twice that week
that I was gonna die.
Yeah. And next thing
you know, bam, I'm dead.
I wake up to this guy going like this,
you know, chest convulsions or whatever.
Boom. I hopped up.
I was like thinking it
was going to be the EMT.
Now I just got up and ran.
Didn't even care what direction.
I left my bike, everything.
I just fucking ran.
And I made about 20 feet
and then I collapsed,
hit the ground again.
He's like, "Relax, relax."
You know, I was like "Oh, shit."
And I was all scuffed up
cause I was riding a bike,
and when I collapsed, you know,
bars went sideways and I fell and stuff.
And so I'm bleeding on
my face and I was like...
And he's like, "I called
the ambulance about..."
I was like, "How long?", you know.
About seven minutes ago.
I was like, "Oh, shit,
it's time to go." You know?
And so I grabbed my stuff
and got back up to Seattle,
got my bill fixed or
whatever with the shit I had.
But it was a pretty traumatic experience.
- [Mark] What would cause that you think?
The drug you're using-
- Exhaustion,
malnourishment,
lack of sleep,
lack of...
Yeah, and the drugs, you know,
affecting heart rate and
blood pressure or whatever.
- [Mark] Did you think your
upbringing, your childhood,
your mom's addiction, all
of your family addiction
is kind of what kind of
put you on this path?
- In a weird way, yeah.
I know the difference between
right and wrong, you know,
being that I grew up around a lot of bad
and then what's, you know,
what school and everything was trying
to teach me what's right.
So like going back and forth,
my uncle,
he's a big influence of mine.
Like I remember it was
like the first memories
of my life going to my
grandma's house, hanging out.
My mom's like slumped out,
been asleep for three, four days,
and everybody's partying at my grandma's
downstairs basement getting high and shit.
And I was a kid, you know,
three years old, four years old.
And I'm watching my uncle come in
with a stack of hundred
dollar bills like that.
He's like, "Austin.
Help me count this."
You know?
And I'm like, "Okay", you know.
As a kid, like, "Heck yeah,
let me get some." You know,
he's like, "No, no no."
Well, my grandma runs a state business
takes care of developmentally
disabled people.
And she's an angel,
she's an angel, but
you know,
that doesn't pay the bills to be an angel.
And so the business that she was running
was in a wealthier part
of the Seattle East side
and my uncle going to school or
because he'd get hand me
down clothes and stuff.
And these people were driving around
and BMWs in freshman year, you know?
And he got made fun of, and
he's like, got tired of it.
I'm just taking a stand for myself.
So, you know, he did.
He would...
He had the gift of the gab.
He would hustle these
people out of everything
with just words.
And he's clean cut, you know.
Clean cut dude and then it became...
Next thing you know, my grandma's house
is getting raided by the feds.
And he got caught with a
pound of meth at 19 years old
in the late 90s.
- [Mark] (indistinct)
- At 19. Yeah.
- [Mark] It sounds like your
family kind of...(laughs)
It was not maybe the
best influence I know.
- No. Yeah, no.
And it's like,
I don't...
I know that what the outcome is.
My uncle spent 20 years
in prison on and off.
I have no relationship with him.
I've seen him beat the hell out of some
people, you know, women and men.
And
I don't want to be that guy.
There's no need.
I want to do something that like changes
the world, you know?
Unity. That's like brings
unity, a true unity, you know?
People always take my
kindness for weakness.
I'm a good guy. I'm a kind guy
but
I'm also the fucking most fucked up
person in the world, dude.
These people who do work hard is...
I feel a lot of guilt
because sometimes I get
into places and I'm like,
"Oh, shit. This person works
every day of their life.
They get up every day
and they work their asses off
to just try and provide
for their families."
And, I didn't even realize what I did
until it's way too late.
I'm like, "Damn. I took
all this from these really,
probably good people that would've
give you the clothes off
their back." You know?
And it's like, that's
what I want to change.
I just want to hit that one big one.
Hit the lottery one time.
Bam. And be able to just give, you know,
Take a little bit for
myself to be comfortable,
and to...
Be able to finance my dreams, you know,
my endeavors.
But I also want to give
back to the, you know,
people who truly do deserve
it, you know? (sniffs)
- [Mark] Austin, thank you so much for
talking to me.
- Thank you. This kind of...
I'm not used to this.
Thank you.
- [Mark] Yeah. I'm sure you haven't shared
a lot of this before, right?
- No, I mean, I preach it every day but
people don't really care, it seems like.
It seems like a lot of them out here,
they respect you, you know?
- [Mark] Not in this neighborhood.
It's hard to get anybody...
Anyone's ear down here.
- Yeah.
But if it saved, man, that'd be so cool.
Like my daughter.
I got to go turn myself in.
I'm going to turn myself in on
a bunch of the dumb I've done
because I need to get my health back.
I need to get a real surgeon.
Like Seattle is really
known for their healthcare.
Get my leg fixed, but I
have to bite the bullet
and man up for the dumb ass shit I did.
- [Mark] Have you done prison time?
- No, but I've spent quite a
bit in jail and I looked at...
I'm looking at prison time.
- [Mark] So if you're turning yourself in,
that means prison time?
- Quite possibly, yeah.
But I'm willing to
sacrifice that to make sure
that I can be there in the later years
because I actually care
about my life now, you know?
I just wish that one day I could just go
and get a lot of dollar scratch ticket
and hit for like the 25,000 or some shit,
but...
But we'll see.
- [Mark] All right.
Thank you so much.
- Yeah, thanks.